all right so we had to do one story on
Isis that I saw this morning
Tatooine which you probably know from
Star Wars that's where Luke and his
family lived was the desert planet
Tatooine was shot and filmed in back in
the 70s in Tunisia in a city in a town
called Tatooine chat am i right on all
the time all right on this and it has
just fallen the actual town it's spelled
slightly differently than the way they
did it in Star Wars but the actual town
of Tatooine has fallen to Isis you know
we did a story a couple weeks ago about
Isis destroying all these artifacts in
Iraq and to create these things the
ancient artifacts that have existed for
you know hundreds and thousands of years
and when I saw a story was it's
incredibly upsetting but this one I mean
Star Wars I've got it in the set right
there I love Star Wars almost everything
I believe is based in Star Wars in the
book like this one hit me in a different
way I was like I mean this this [ __ ] is
just completely out of control and I
know that sounds crazy because they're
beheading people and burning people and
I don't want to dismiss any of that but
when you can actually destroy future
artifacts that that's a strange thing
whoo that's good that's powerful right
right I guess what we call a thinker
whoa
that was right because that's something
that yours from now people doing right
and there were just months ago they
literally they had tours to go there
people would go on vacation and see
where Star Wars was shot and it's
literally being overtaken by a do you
think this will actually motivate the
American public to get behind real
military action now because there's Star
Wars so does you know I know you're
being slightly sarcastic but I was a
little more for military action there
are at least fire of a Death Star you
had a recruitment office near my house
that you know and clearly these are the
droids they're looking for but but there
is something serious here because it is
there's a fondness yeah we all have a
personal fondness to this mythology in
the story and this memories from our
childhood of seeing this these films and
so it does hit us in a very interesting
real way right so that these other
things are far away and horrible but
don't actually hit us personally
part I completely agree if it's right in
the Star Wars culture of you know what
what better metaphor for the dark side
of the force
Wow yeah then Isis oh man you know yeah
that even even the Arab nations are
starting to yeah is it Saudi Arabia
there's now lining up their troops at
the border make yeah now I'm going to
start no I kept these attacking them
Jordan's attacking them so even I look
so isn't that the interesting part of
this that's fine is that it is that the
good part of everything that's happening
with Isis that maybe some of the rest of
the world
yeah like they've like Star Wars is
gonna push everybody rich but other
nations are finally being like this
shit's going on in our backyard and that
maybe America doesn't have to do every
you better marry you your ass away from
my tattoo we bring us home you kids out
there you like to do fun videos someone
dress up in cosplay and do a cosplay
versus Isis oh that's a member does that
happen one of you listeners Watchers out
there yeah like like Raphael from Ninja
Turtles versus that it sounds like golly
gee how about c-3po trying to negotiate
with one of these two hottie John or
whatever these where is he when you need
him anyway what do you guys think it's a
terrible story did the idea that this
town is being ransacked by Isis no no
it's it's really upsetting to me what do
you think could Star Wars start getting
people to gin up maybe do you think
should we do anything let us know in the
comments right down below